how do we analyze this this is why i
asked you to put some spaces in between
okay i'm going to name these
coefficients
where shall i put these
i'm going to put them over here
i'm going to call the coefficients um c
of k
c okay see the coefficient now
sometimes the textbook will call them
lowercase t
i find that somewhat confusing but
you'll see it sometimes which is why i
wanted to clue you into it
so they'll write it like this okay what
it means is i just want the number part
that you guys are used to coefficients
right
so how do i generalize this well
here for example okay i've got four
coefficients i can call them c0
c1 c2 and c3 corresponding to the fact
that this is entry zero or three true
zero three choose one
you get the idea okay now
which one is bigger like can i write
some inequalities that tell me which one
is bigger and which ones are smaller
right
c naught is less than c one
right so i write this inequality is that
okay
what inequality what kind of
relationship is there between the c1 and
c2
coefficients they're equal
but now that i've passed over the
greatest coefficient a transition right
c2 is not less than c3 it's bigger
right so i'm getting this kind of shape
it's exactly symmetrical
reflecting the fact that it's just the
standard pascal's triangle coefficients
all right have a look at the next one
okay again i've got c naught
one c two c three one six twelve eight
i'm still less than right i'm climbing
up
this one's still less than and now i can
say twelve is bigger than eight so you
can see
what you're looking for the signal
you're looking for is there's a tipping
point
right when the less than less than less
than less than that turns into a greater
than
okay that's when you know aha here i am
that's the biggest one
or these guys equally are the biggest
ones
do one more time or two more times
finish it for this one
what happens come on you can tell me
what happens
what are all of the signs they're all
less than it never actually transitions
right so if it's never if it never turns
around it just means well the last one
must be the biggest
okay all right now the last one yeah you
see
naught c1 c2 c3
because i flipped the numbers around
right
in a matter of speaking that the change
the tipping points already happened
right so instead of this one we never
turned around it was an increasing
function so you pick the last one
this is a decreasing function so you
pick the first one
there you go okay so what i'm looking
for is something to do with these
inequalities right
let's try and generalize this and see if
we can take this approach
uh let's see okay
okay where am i at the same page
okay
i'm going to try and solve for k right k
will tell me
where is the greatest coefficient
what point am i looking for you'd say it
a couple of different ways right
the way that the textbook presents and
you'll see it in the hsc as well they'll
often say
prove this and part one then parts will
be fine the actual greatest one is
i want to satisfy this inequality what
does this mean look at it with me
okay when this inequality is satisfied
it means that
the next coefficient is bigger than the
current one
does that make sense as long as the next
coefficient's bigger than the current
one
i'm climbing can you see it have a look
see the next coefficient
is bigger than the current one and the
next coefficient is bigger than the
current one
and up now i transition so i should
solve that's the one i want
okay so this means
subsequent coefficients
are increasing okay if i can satisfy
this
it'll tell me where the greatest one is
okay now where you'll see this is is
if i divide like this
okay provided that
there's a restriction can anyone see
where the restriction is
the coefficient has to be positive right
because if it's not positive what
happens
then it would it would change the
direction of the inequality right and
this kind of thing breaks down
okay so what we're going to try and do
is come up with a general expression for
that guy
okay this guy here right once i've got
that then i solve him for greater than 1
and i can get my value out